giving a shout out to Joe Biden thank
you President Joe Biden
NBC news says White House bans trans
activists for a topless photo at Pride
event it was a video Rose Montoya a
trans model an activist said she was
living her truth and wasn't trying to be
vulgar or profane
but in fact that's exactly what this
person was doing jumping up and down
topless with two other trans individuals
and exposing their their bare chests now
you can make the argument that it's
legal to do so in in Washington DC sure
under the 14th Amendment if men are
allowed to go out without shirts on then
women are as well but this is the White
House this is a formal event
this is an individual who showed up
took their top off and all that stuff
let me just read the story we'll get
into it the White House said a
transgender model would be banned from
future events due to photos and videos
that show her topless in the South lawn
during an lgbtq pride month celebration
on Saturday that's individual just for
clarification is biologically male Rose
Montoya a trans-modeling activist was
among hundreds invited by Biden Montoya
shared a video from the event on
Instagram that features a clip of first
standing in front of the White House
topless covering her nipples with her
hands right-wing media shared
screenshots from montoya's video with
commentators and media personalities
calling her actions disrespectful well
the White House spokesperson said
Tuesday that Montoya and the other
people featured would be banned from
future events organized there this
behavior is inappropriate and
disrespectful for any event at the White
House it is not reflective of the event
we hosted to celebrate lgbtqi families
or other hundreds of guests who were in
attendance
the White House spokesperson said
individuals in the video will not be
invited to future events now Candace
Owens has been critical of Biden for
inviting these people knowing full well
what these people do I can agree with
that however I think we should be
praising the Biden Administration Kareem
Jean-Pierre and all of the Democrats in
the white house right now for this why
this behavior that we're seeing is
commonplace at Pride parades and pride
events in fact substantially worse
things go on correct if this was a pride
event
and this is inappropriate and
unacceptable and warranting a ban for
more than one individual and that's Joe
Biden who said it well that's wonderful
two things we want Joe Biden Democrats
in the establishment to back off this
stuff to lose that fight we want these
people to quite literally say Sheamus
you were right the whole time we're
sorry and now we agree with you and
that's exactly what Joe Biden is is
starting with it with this process in
doing so the Democrats are now agreeing
with us we're winning that fight why am
I going to complain about it the most
important thing is in terms of how we
address the conversation the next time
to each and every one of you people out
there listening with your liberal aunt
or or you know family member who is
always telling you you're wrong now you
only need say one thing look I I don't
know about all that but I agree with Joe
Biden on this one this stuff is
inappropriate and and is disrespectful
that's it so now when they say oh you
Trump is no no I'm with Joe Biden on
this one you know Joe Biden came out his
administration saying this stuff
shouldn't be happening he's right come
on man I'm Catholic we don't believe in
that this is indecent but it creates a
tribal conundrum for many of these
individuals if their whole identity is
just hating Trump but now all of a
sudden you their supposed political
enemy is saying no Biden was right
what's their response going to be
Biden's wrong okay absolutely get them
to start condemning Joe Biden yeah I
absolutely agree with you I do think
though it is also important to point out
the hypocrisy of them like like Candace
said she like you know who you're
inviting so yeah you know that this is
moral indecent you just admitted it and
yet you inflated them anyway knowing
that they were likely to behave like
they behave at all other Pride events
what's wrong with you let me show you
these tweets uh uh because I think
there's actually a good exchange between
uh Candace and myself Candace Owens says
Rose Montoya is the name of the man who
exposed his surgically created breasts
to young children at the White House the
White House invited rose knowing fully
well that he advocates for the teaching
of sex to young children he advocates
for this openly on his Instagram page
now I I disagree with that sentiment and
and I responded you should be praising
Biden he actually condemned trans
activists and uh Candace responded
you're missing the point entirely Biden
is only condemning this act because his
voters were outraged he invited this
individual to the White House knowing
what this individual was and exactly how
they behaved in public his entire
Instagram is dedicated to debauchery I
said after realizing it was hurting him
he backtracked now his RPI response now
you praised Biden in order to push the
story and force him to keep condemning
the Behavior now we say this LGBT Pride
stuff where they danced naked at parades
is bad I agree with Joe Biden that's my
point by all means I certainly
understand what Candace is saying the
Biden Administration these these
individuals know who they're inviting
what they do but what you need to
understand about many of these people is
their fair weather politicians if they
see in public people saying it's good
they say sure fine whatever but then all
of a sudden they engage in the behavior
and it goes bad and they're getting a
big backlash
if the only options you present towards
the bite Administration Democrats
liberals or whatever is always no matter
what you do we're mad at you then
they'll just write you off if you say
you know what I disagree with you on
politics I think the Biden family is
deeply corrupt but in this in this one
thank you for doing the right thing and
condemning this Behavior
If this means they faced a backlash um
if Joe Biden faced a backlash among his
voters that was so severe he actually
condemned this that means we are winning
and this kind of loot behavior is now
being condemned by the president like
that's culture War Victory like the one
of the best we've seen now you can go to
each and every one of those liberal
family members and friends and be like
look even Joe Biden's calling this out
will you now take it take a second to
listen to me I think it's victory I
think I say thanks Biden I appreciate it
I really I really sincerely mean it it
was the right thing to do I absolutely
see it as a victory too after he
denounced it or disavowed it absolutely
it's a it's a moral Victory because any
time that they continue to like be half
naked you can say that's wrong it's not
good enough for the White House it's not
good enough for my kids school but but
it's just it was a pride event this
person went topless and Biden said this
is wrong and disrespectful and you know
what he's absolutely correct about that
is wrong and disrespectful that I think
the big issue as to why this this debate
is happening is is because people don't
want this stuff around kids
and and and that's it
when Bud Light thought thought they were
winning they absolutely sponsored these
events it hurt them Target it hurt them
calls it's hurting them North Face it's
hurting them all these companies are now
facing this massive backlash the White
House it's hurting them all this massive
cultural shift it's like it's like
victories around the corner man I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna look a gift horse in
the mouth you know what I mean like Joe
Biden's coming out being like I guess
you guys win I'm like that's right you
were right the whole time I used to
think that Puritans were so far behind
the the curve but now I'm realizing in
real time how how Society can become
aberrant I've never seen it in my life
I'm 44 and never saw like real
like derogatory Behavior take mainstream
attention it's always been like yeah
blackout drunk that's disgusting drug
addicts gross uh sex in public
disgusting like I knew that stuff
but now like I see why the peer why
people are Puritans in general like you
do need to protect people's minds it
can't just just because something is
real it doesn't mean it's okay to see I
wanna I wanna address some of what
people are saying real quick sorry okay
go ahead go ahead uh we've got uh some
super chats one says don't praise them
they only did it because of the Uproar
another person says don't praise your
enemies you're not gonna teach them
anything
in in any conflict
the end result is not the eradication of
of your enemy and in some instances
that's what they try to make happen for
sure you know genocide has existed
throughout history it's horrifying but
in most wars it is the subjugation of
your rival
someone declares One Another Country
what do they do they occupy that country
and then use the people of their country
towards their ends it is not just like
they go in there and say now we will
remove these people like certainly it's
happened but that's not typical
in terms of uh only doing it after
uproar that's what we want to happen
someone does something bad we say rabble
rabble rabble they say okay we're sorry
we say thank you and then we continue
through it's like you've claimed the
battlefield they've surrendered and laid
down their arms and said you win and we
go okay now the battlefield is ours now
we're going to dictate the terms in
terms of you know not praising or
anything he says don't praise your
enemies you crush them
when we get to the point where all of
these corporations are agreeing with us
in order to make them continue agreeing
with us we now must give them positive
incentive we said what you're doing is
bad they said screw you we said it's bad
we're not going to buy your products now
we stop buying their products now
they're they're markets tanking and
they're panicking if we don't buy their
products what will they do they'll say
okay we're gonna double down now is the
opportunity to say hey wow you know
these companies are are backtracking
give them an incentive to sell to you
and they will shift even further in your
direction so I know to a lot of people
it may seem counterintuitive because
you're angry at what many of these
corporations were doing and what Biden
has done and is doing and it's not just
about the culture War but you've gotta
you've got a plan for how you actually
win this and what your end goals are
going to be if the if we truly want
these people to stop targeting kids and
stop the loot and lascivious behavior in
public and in schools we have to utilize
the the this the statement from the
president we have to use it I wonder oh
we're gonna say this it's a step in the
right direction but it also so I see
what you're saying it's a step in the
right direction and we want to encourage
like good behavior like with any
children you want to encourage good
behavior but it's not it's not it's only
a piece of it for the rest of it like
they knew this guy promotes you know
being degenerate in front of children
and they invited him like where's the
apology for that are you just
apologizing person took a shirt off
right is that the only reason that the
apology is there
three people taking their shirt off and
the white house but is it where is the
outrage and the apology for inviting
these people that you that you knew were
degenerate to begin with and and
Advocate it for things that most of the
country disagrees where's where's that I
don't think you're gonna get that yeah
not from the White House not from a
political power they'll they'll ban the
enemy the enemies
it's a good start but we have to get to
the other it's we can't declare I don't
know I agree it's not about declaring
Victory it's about there's two paths the
the Democrats can go down right now and
corporations and everyone it is doubling
down on their behaviors like Bud Light
is currently doing or it's saying okay
we were wrong and going the direction
the only way someone will change their
their life their work
the only way that they'll change the
thing they're fighting for is if there
is a path of least resistance and a and
a light at the end of the tunnel if you
create a roadblock in front of them no
matter what they do they will keep doing
what they're doing it's just there's
there's no other it's just simple logic
you you say to the bite Administration I
hate you and you're wrong they're gonna
be like what was the point of
apologizing we got nothing for it it
made us look worse now everyone's mad at
us just keep doing what you're doing and
latch on to the fans you have yeah
really come out we say no you're doing a
good job they're going to be like hey
we're winning over people by doing this
let's keep doing more of it right we
want them to try to win our approval so
we have to offer like I said I agree
incentive just to keep up with the kid
but it's to me that's like we still have
to we still have to keep pushing them
further and further and further yeah I
would agree I mean I think we have to
let people know what they're not getting
so you're right that there's an apology
here but then there's also a question of
well is he addressing the fact that he
did invite this person who was promoting
horrible stuff in the first place right
I mean there wasn't an apology for that
and you're right that we're probably not
gonna get one I just think it's
important for people to know that you
haven't gotten that right they haven't
made this right they've pushed a little
bit in the right direction but it's
they're there are a lot of bad people
who get invited to the White House the
first question right now that we can
address is the behavior at the White
House yeah and it's really there may be
someone who's done something horrendous
and they got invited after the fact and
it certainly has happened with a lot of
people like Obama invited certain people
uh there's a lot of people we could name
that uh oh we can talk about the Weather
Underground for instance and these
people who have sorted passed and Trump
invited Milo I mean they're they're
questionable people that get invited who
have done who have done things the
question is first and foremost
were they was it proper decorum for the
White House and the fact that they're
saying no to this means we now have the
opportunity to say if it's not good for
the White House why is it good for the
public streets if he was upset that it
was in front of kids here why not why
not be upset that was in front of kids
elsewhere this is this is it right here
man now when it comes to the schools if
someone says why why do you care so much
about what's going on in these schools
and I'll be like I just look I agree
with Biden on this one they shouldn't be
showing kids this stuff this is so good
for ads though for Republican ads they
should have the slogan remember how
everybody was saying bring back decency
to the White House by having Biden come
in and say this is your decency and show
the White House and and like a
background picture with the zipper marks
and the
yeah with the fake boobs and say this is
this is what you voted for this is
decency brought back to the wedding and
what is Biden going to say and what is
Biden say I already said I was sorry man
but this is you can't run on that but no
but he will say this and then the
response will be so did you not vet the
individuals or did you know and regret
it after the fact but but that is true I
think conservatives are going to this is
this is it for 2024. no no question they
are going to run these ads in Suburban
districts targeting women relentlessly
it will work it's going to be Suburban
moms who are going to be like I am
outraged that this happened this is not
decency in fact it's worse than Trump
they said Trump was the lewd old man and
he was he was pottymouth but it was
Biden who brought the people to come in
and take their shirts off and jiggle
them in front of a camera and that's the
thing people miss about Biden
intentionally so in the media is it's
not like we went from Trump who is
abrasive and angry and mean to people to
Biden who's nice and sweet we just got
someone who is equal believe not more
abrasive and mean but way less funny
right Biden did not bring decency to the
White House he's just very creepy he's
very gross and he's also very mean there
was nothing decent or adult about him in
his entire career yeah I don't I do want
to I'll point out real quick uh
Trump was supposed to speak at 8 15.
they pushed at 8 30. they pushed to 8
45. so uh making them wait D well you
know he's gotta he's coming back and
he's doing his thing so uh you know well
I feel like that's a typical Trump I
can't remember the last time he was on
time for anything I think he wants he's
loving it thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time